[Music]
and morbid mediation news meditation
mediation drinkin
meditation is submitted by a self fluffy
fluffy fluffy lovely I wanna die mmm-hmm
and university is offering students an
actual grave to lion to cope with exam
stress huh I don't know what that means
do I need to read it one more time I
think you've read it wrong is it cuz
done I think I read it correctly it was
written wrong
I said mediation initially and I had to
change it to meditation foo so I read it
correctly after that yeah I think the
students going like I'm so stressed out
I want to die no well you could just lay
in this grave for now die yes and then
you don't want to be dead
so now go up and study maybe that set is
confusing alright so I have a video to
show you guys
oh god there's a video for this mm-hmm
and oh he'll know about it so this is
you're scared in the Netherlands
oh is it in snow and [ __ ] oh oh and not
us news well they just get a hooker why
don't they get a hooker it's in the
Netherlands it was a very unique
experience because I've never been so
close to nature before and normally when
I meditate my thoughts go all over the
place I think about school about work or
anything and it's okay it just seems
like a ghetto sensory deprivation pain
alright
well in the ground they here called rise
in jail what it really contextualizes
life yeah it's like is this really worth
getting all [ __ ] worked up for it's a
damn exam
you know say I know that is actually
yeah hmm makes you do [ __ ] did you die
no that don't come clean that's my
resting energy I feel like at all times
what's your resting energy almost dead
what how people feel probably in that
coffin is I'm always like what did you
die there's so much [ __ ] that you could
stress about but to me it's not actually
die until it's dark yeah if that makes
sense isn't it fun to act stress though
mmm no I'm in the I stress myself out
and I've had to learn how to dress
myself no I'm still learning
I mean you shape I'm like one of those
like what I'm a warrior
I'm warrior huh I'm not a warrior I'm a
warrior and I make up I'm like I had to
learn how to like stop making up
scenarios in my head worst case like
this and like the constant anxiety
depression I don't want to get out of
bed like I've had to I want to see the
other day had to go you feel this it's
okay you got an hour now after that get
up and for some reason I was like oh
[ __ ] that worked and then I went about
my day have you ever heard of the it
could always be worse attitude sometimes
I'm like and oh it could always get
worse so I'm like why stress the [ __ ]
out of my I hear people say that I'm
like so I'm already thinking it's are
you where have you ever seen a lady
Panhandle with a baby in her arms and
you go yep there's not much I should be
worrying about right now sometimes it's
so selfish though like anxiety isn't
about what could be worse I don't give a
[ __ ] it's like if I'm anxiety or
whatever it's so it just works for me I
know but that's your thing yeah so my
thing is not it could be worse but I'm
just like I don't care if it's worse but
then I'm good snaps you well um you
still got other things you want to do oh
and then I always think about what my
family would have to deal with
I think that's if you die so yeah I
always that's like one thing if I don't
do this then what are they I would
always that's that one thing that kind
of snaps me out I don't worry about
whatever anybody else is going through
because I'm being selfish that's me with
my son then you go everybody has like
their things because yours is like it
could be worse then you're like okay
cool
that's why I call this my resting energy
right like like to say that it could be
worse to someone in a tailspin does not
help them at all like it's just it's
just you might as well just leave them
alone while they [ __ ] spin out that's
a lot of people do that right like well
it could be worse well someone's like
freaking out and it doesn't help them
like or the fake positives right have to
come from them but if it's from yourself
like we'll tell you I am in the cracks
in a literal tailspin yeah well I guess
I could be upside-down car accident
Iceland whatever I'm just flying yeah
and it's totally one of those things
like you should feel grateful there's so
many people that will probably see that
and that are thinking how ungrateful are
these people to go and play around with
death like that to feel better about an
exam cuz they can go to school they had
enough like yeah that's fun but but you
see how like a lot of people will say
that [ __ ] but everybody has everything I
think as long as you acknowledge that
like for her that could have saved her
[ __ ] whole life like she could have
like realized that oh [ __ ] these exams
are only one level and look at me now
physically in the ground
[ __ ] I don't want to be here it's
all prospective yeah cuz in Japan a lot
of people commit suicide when they fail
exams but exams College is where most of
the [ __ ] goes down let's me that's your
first time being an individual is my do
Ocoee up until that point you have
somebody telling you what to do where to
go when to go there no one teaches you
how to be on your own true unless you're
in that type of environment
nobody says this but college is the
closest thing to [ __ ] gambling I've
ever heard of Oh God I just spent 30
grand on this next year and I'm about to
fail which means I'm gonna have to spend
that again mmm this is like and what
about all the kids with the professional
degrees that are graduating with like
two $300,000 in debt yeah starting state
you start starting at negative yes like
that needs to could you imagine though
it like you said it's a sleep
deprivation tank what's that's a
deprivation sensory there we go some
people don't even want to like deal with
that much of themselves it's hard I've
ever done sensory - I do sleep hypnosis
so I have to sit there what sleep
hypnosis pretty much is the saintly talk
down there it's more like they put you
in scenarios like in a lot of depending
on what you're going for and
help with whatever your goal is like I
think I had one the other night that
it's like trying to meet like yourself
or see your future self so what it is is
just you're you're hearing and you're
following in your mind a lot of the
scenarios that they're telling you to go
through but it forces you to get outside
of whatever other [ __ ] you have or
to address the [ __ ] mmm sleep
hypnosis I mean I don't know how much
but it did get me from being unable to
sleep at night so now I can go to sleep
to the point to where now I don't even
need it
last time I've learned how like I've
learned how to shut my brain off cuz I
have to wake up at like early in the
morning and I was working till like I
used to work till like 4:00 or 5:00 in
the morning and then have to be at work
at like 6:00 a.m. yeah oh so and I did
that for like nine years but everybody
has to figure out cuz it could be worse
right I could have not had a job and why
can't you go to sleep and I try to
figure it out but you know what's pretty
cool watching monkeys eat bananas and
play it does that does that help you
like watching animals watching owls yeah
it's like a primitive thing like it just
brings me back to reality and shoes mmm
that's your type of meditation the hell
should we go to sleep oh no I don't have
problems going to sleep oh that's sister
I could just [ __ ] around and bone and I
just turn it off but I did though for
like most of my life yeah but I don't
know now I'm cool I'm just uh tired I
turn off the phone I just knock out yeah
dude you know what helps me is like I
think about how everyone's always says
like we're all so [ __ ] up Betina in
the internet and I'm like dude you look
anywhere else there's so much
destruction [ __ ] everywhere oh my god
this is just destruction everywhere like
a son becomes a super red giant and then
it sucks inside of itself becomes a
black hole starts sucking all the matter
around it inside oh yeah destructions
everywhere [ __ ] look at nature every
day a [ __ ] bird wakes up it tries not
to die and get killed by a predator and
then the [ __ ] worm tries not to get
killed by the bird there's so much of
that and we what we go home we were like
I gotta watch TV and the news is like
yeah I remember one day it was like I
was driving I was looking I was like how
do these birds like you know everybody
has like those kind of moments where
you're not just trying to be super
selfish and like I gotta get to work and
you're looking around like did I just
take this birds home how do we deal with
this [ __ ] on daily basis dude one time a
bird made its home in my laundry she
and I had to get it blasted out like
3000 psi of pressure Oh
launch get out I saw the bird nest just
[ __ ] fly out the side of my face
because then I could use my dryer again
we saw it on the outside that if you put
laundry in it wouldn't get dry and I was
like mm-hmm no no not today bird yeah
move - it somewhere else let's launch
down it like 60 miles an hour
really I tried to worry about the birds
and he's like listen this [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] boos of all deals
nests get it the [ __ ] his air he knows
what it is it could be worse yep go and
sit in a grave with that [ __ ] rebuild
[ __ ] that's truth you must rebuild this
yep the air is what the burbs was we're
good at anyways right I'm like there's
plenty of sticks out there yeah you'll
[ __ ] fly somewhere else nobody cares
if the rest of the nest didn't how to
fly it whatever learned survival of the
fittest there could have been there
could not have been I don't know I'll
never know I guess oh this grave they
call it the purification grave I want to
lay in there complete with a blanket and
yoga mat that's nice that's comfy
you could book it for like hours
sessions and there was this one guy that
got interviewed and said that he was
trying to - to go in but it would think
there was a long waiting list oh they
just made me anxiety just waiting in
line I mean that sounds way less
dramatic than when you first read it I'm
thinking of somebody like putting you in
a coffin yeah if you're going around
lower to do that that's what I was
thinking what was going on not a hole on
the ground there just laying and you're
looking like that which it's a [ __ ]
perspective that's what I'm thinking
what have you got a p2 right when you
get in the confident they're like
slamming
shut oh [ __ ] I saw that they did that um
and oh no it was Kill Bill
no it was a curio churn euphoria when
they did that like so sobriety X
exercise where they had a mirror often
no but they were just looking in it
that's true thanks to myself - Korea
yeah that's intensive training with
death is also liberating mm-hmm
they say sleeping is actually you
playing in between the two realms I buy
it because I have sleep paralysis and I
see some [ __ ] up [ __ ] that I might I
think this is kind of real Oh bug yeah
you get a uh regularly yeah I'd like to
hear more I'll tell you it's interesting
it's pretty what's wild ass [ __ ] it's
scary
yeah yeah we I don't know if you want to
know I want to know scary
scaly I don't think I want a tree on
only
[Music]